i'm feeling good how about you andy you  doing good i am doing great conan i mean  man  oh man it sure is great to be at work  today  yeah well of course we had a little time  off but now we're back at it  yeah but seriously conan i really mean  it i mean off weeks  they're great for relaxation leisure and  renewal but  being here with my pal conan and making  tv i mean this  is where life happens this is really  where my soul sings  oh man crap andy someone sure drank  their sarcasm juice this morning  conan i didn't drink sarcasm juice i ate  irony bites  the tasty treat that helps you say the  opposite of what you mean  [Music]  can i put the box down yeah okay  are they even they're not even a real  sponsor so we made no money from that  no yeah in fact what's in here yeah  any real cookies in there oh they're  like little uh vanilla wafers  yeah don't mind me